what's your problem the the director
in front of everybody the bottom line is
i'm sitting there and i hear you guys
wow seeing shady
cause for business has different
branches if they hear us
why are you doing this in front of your
father and in front of everybody
i'm done with you milk my dad
andre has these motives
he's got things that he wants to do
with my dad and it doesn't involve
us when i started working with my dad
like
five years ago i had a lot of ideas too
but my dad didn't entertain any of my
ideas
so i'm just seeing it for what it really
is
my dad is being manipulated by him
and i can't take it anymore
dad you should be out there talking to
them too you started it
they're two adults it doesn't matter
you're in the middle of this too i'm
listening to my dad can we hurry up the
babies are
just silly is he yelling at my wife a
lot dude i wouldn't let him yell at her
this is not what i wanted exactly like i
have to clarify something
she's saying all this stuff dad i heard
all your conversations no for real
you said what you're going to talk about
now you're really
what i want is us not to talk about
business on the rv
i already said that
[Music]
you